la prison pour femmes n'est pas une blague j'ai accouché dans
des chaînes littérales et c'est comme ça que vous faites passer de
l'eau à travers une porte en prison
[Musique] les
coussinets peuvent être utilisés comme tant de choses
semelles intérieures pour vos chaussures je peux l'utiliser pour
nettoyer la cellule je pourrais l'utiliser comme  un
masque de sommeil je pourrais en faire des tampons
ce que je devais faire dans
l'arkansas pour survivre à une période comment faire passer
l'eau avec un sac à puces en prison ce que
vous voulez faire est de le faire passer par la
porte comme ça
nous sommes  sur le point de vous montrer comment faire
ces enveloppes de prison bien votre pâte est
la plus importante vous prenez juste des
craquelins du commissaire nous avons ajouté des
biscuits pour rendre la pâte sucrée ajoutez de
l'eau
quoi que vous soyez si vous respectez l'homme l'homme
vous respecte et c'est juste la loi de
la prison c'est juste une question de respect je
ne ferais pas
pipi sur les toilettes et laisserais la paix les choses
sur les toilettes c'est comme non c'est
irrespectueux parce que nous partageons cet
espace et ce n'est qu'un et nous sommes
confinés
et donc même en enlevant vos chaussures
parce que quand j'ai d'abord
je suis entré j'ai mis mes chaussures
ne jamais s'asseoir sur le lit de quelqu'un c'est tellement
irrespectueux d'aller s'asseoir sur le
lit de quelqu'un d'autre
donner naissance enchaîné a été l'une des
choses les plus difficiles que j'ai jamais eu à
traverser et puis ma fille m'a été arrachée
des bras
après deux jours et elle a été placée en
famille d'accueil et j'ai été renvoyée en prison
imaginez-vous dans la position la plus
inconfortable dans laquelle vous pouvez être vous
savez quand vous transpirez quand vous avez
les nerfs à vif quand vous
tremblez visiblement et  tu essaies d'
aimer
je ne sais pas essayer d'aimer faire face à ce qui
se passe c'était à chaque
instant de chaque jour en prison
j'ai vu des gens mourir j'ai été en
isolement pendant longtemps
mentalement ce n'est pas facile  j'ai été
aspergé de gaz poivré j'ai été battu alors
quand j'ai été emmené au trou, les gardes ont
à peu près appuyé sur leur bouton, les sirènes
se sont déclenchées
pour leur faire savoir envoyer l'équipe de crétins
ils vous attrapent vous amènent au trou
et ensuite ils vous jettent dedans  une cellule et
te dépouiller de tout ce que tu possédais quand j'étais
dans le trou de la prison d'état de l'utah une
fois ils m'ont mis près de la casse et
c'était l'hiver dehors et il neigeait ils
ont laissé la porte ouverte toute la nuit
j'ai eu des ennuis alors ils m'ont pris mon
matelas de moi donc je n'avais pas de
matelas tout ce que j'avais était une couverture les
flics ont oublié de me rendre mon matelas
j'ai dû dormir par terre avec une
couverture et ma combinaison
[Musique]
je me suis fait un bon ami pendant que je  était en
prison, il est en fait devenu mon mentor, il
s'appelle Tony Vincent Crechiola et il a
86 ans. Tony purge actuellement une
peine de 99 ans pour le meurtre d'un
conseiller municipal du Minnesota.
chemin tu vas être au
même endroit avec moi il m'a envoyé lire
des livres comme le prince de nicola
machiavelli um livre de robert green les
48 lois du pouvoir il m'enverrait
lire frederick nietzsche euh des tonnes de
différents livres de médecine histoire politique
tout ce que j'apprenais de ces gars
qui ont été en prison pendant 20 à 30 ans, mon
père n'a pas toujours fait partie de ma vie et
il a donc fallu qu'un homme en prison m'apprenne en quelque sorte
à aimer passer du fil dentaire
[Musique]
étant refusé  emplois, je ne peux pas vous dire à quel
point cela m'a affecté lorsque je suis
revenu dans la société pour la première fois, personne ne voulait
embaucher un camarade, même cinq ans plus tard, je
dois encore présenter mes candidatures
que je suis un criminel condamné et que je peux être
refusé sur la base de  la dernière fois que j'ai entendu dire qu'il n'y
avait que sept pays qui
accepteraient les criminels, ce qui est
vraiment dégoûtant parce que j'ai toujours
voulu aller au canada, je n'ai pas le droit
d'être une mère adoptive, ce qui me rend folle
parce que je veux être une famille d'accueil  parent tellement
flippant qu'on me refusait toujours un
logement je comprends en tant qu'ancien
trafiquant de drogue et délinquant armé je comprends pourquoi
quelqu'un pourrait vous refuser mais c'était une
accusation que j'ai attrapée quand j'avais 19 ans
je suis allé dans une agence de mannequins agissant euh  des
studios de production par intérim et tout ça
et j'ai essayé de m'impliquer j'ai entendu non non non
tu as trop de tatouages ​​j'ai entendu non
pendant six mois probablement et j'étais comme
tu sais que je ne vais pas abandonner cette
agence m'a pris ils ont utilisé  mes
photos et ces photos sont entrées dans
des magazines ces photos sont entrées dans une tonne
de choses différentes qui ont en quelque sorte
fleuri ma carrière je suis sorti et 2016 j'ai
commencé un
travail de soutien au bar qui a duré deux
mois et j'ai immédiatement su que ce
n'est pas  ce n'est pas ce pour quoi je me suis inscrit
et puis j'ai juste
commencé à faire du fitness
et euh
ça a juste grandi parce que j'ai toujours
embrassé qui j'étais et que je revenais de
prison alors comment est-ce que j'ai pu
rester bien dehors  j'ai appris ce qui
se passait dans ma tête j'ai étudié la psychologie
et j'ai tout fait par moi-même